[Music]
[Music]
all right let's get started and talk
about recommender systems guys so uh let
me give you a little bit more about my
bio and we'll open it up for questions
and if there's no questions from the
audience here i have some frequently
asked questions that i can go through as
well that i'm prepared to talk about and
uh we can also go through some code and
actually see a real working recommender
system in action so we got plenty of
material to fill up this time i think
uh but yeah just to tell you a little
bit about me first
let's talk about me
my name is frank kane again i am uh the
president of sundog education and uh
these days i earn a living by making
online video courses on platforms such
as manning
um before that though i spent
nine years working at amazon.com started
there in 2003 as a senior engineer
software engineer and when i started
there they threw me into what they call
the personalization team this was the
guys that were doing personalized
recommendations people who bought also
bought and back then they didn't really
call them recommender systems you know
it wasn't really a thing yet it's just
it was just algorithms it was uh
programming more than anything you know
so we were kind of like blending these
fields of uh you know data science
although it wasn't really call data
science back then uh software
engineering and system engineering at
very large scale and distributed systems
to try to compute these recommendations
for our customers
at least on a daily basis and serve that
in real time you know to thousands and
thousands of transactions per second it
was an exciting place and kind of
learned by getting thrown into the into
the deep end of the pool there you know
but um
you know i managed to swim thankfully
and uh worked my way up to senior
manager by the time i left there um by
the time i was done with my career at
amazon i was actually running the
engineering team for imdb.com which is a
big movie website that's a subsidiary of
amazon lots of fun there like it's it's
just as fun as it sounds
um
but after nine years um my family just
couldn't take the weather in seattle
anymore so we packed up cashed out and
moved to florida that's where we are now
and i've been working for myself ever
since making courses for you so that's
my expertise in recommender systems um i
didn't just do recommender systems at
amazon but it really was the focus of
what i did for most of that time so
between recommender systems and content
optimization and you know larger scale
system engineering work but
personalization was always what it
seemed to come back to for me even at
imdb we had a movie recommender system
and you'll see the the dna of that
experience in my course here because we
lean heavily on making movie
recommendations in this course about
recommender systems because there's some
really fun data sets out there to play
with on that
hey we've got a question and it sounds
like a hard one
how can you determine the minimal size
of previous information needed for a
recommender system to be effective does
it vary by application or platform yes
it varies
it varies very widely there's no real
set answer to that you kind of have to
experiment with it to be honest there's
no there's no formula because it depends
a lot on the sparsity of that data right
it's not just the quantity it's how
sparse it is and that's what's different
about recommender systems
um it's not like normal machine learning
where you have a complete set of
training data like for example if you're
trying to train a system how to identify
a picture of a cat right you throw a ton
of pictures of cats at it that have you
know every pixel in the image filled in
and you can train this neural network to
figure out what a cat looks like right
uh with recommendations it doesn't work
that way um
because a typical person let's say
you're recommending movies let's stick
with that example
the typical person has not seen every
movie in the world right i don't think
anybody has well i know one guy who has
my old boss at imdb called needham he's
i think he's actually seen every movie
but for normal people like you and me
uh by and large we've seen a very tiny
teeny teeny percentage of all the movies
in the world right same idea holds true
for amazon like you have not bought
every item on amazon um that is actually
impossible you've only bought a small
amount of them or you've even viewed a
small amount of them so this is what we
call a sparse data problem
so the amount of information you need
depends not only on the quantity of your
data but also on how sparse that data is
so you know if i have you know five
million data points that people have
bought the same three items but i don't
have any data points for like in the
other 10 million items in your catalog
that's not going to be helpful right
so it's this balance between quantity of
data the sparsity of the data and also
the quality of the data as well that
plays a big role too um
give you an example of that
the best recommendations you will ever
see are based on purchase information
and this is really the secret of why
amazon's recommendations have always
been so good because they can use data
about what people are actually spending
their money on to power and train those
algorithms that they have and there is
no bigger reliable signal of interest
than someone shelling out their cash and
saying i want to spend my money on this
thing right
that's very hard thing to game it's a
very hard thing to fake
very very high quality data right so if
you have a lot
of purchase data and it's not sparsely
distributed that is the ideal situation
and that's the situation that amazon is
in you know so a big part of why their
recommendations are so good is just
because their data is so good
in contrast if you have click-based data
that can be very sketchy right
if someone's clicking on something on
your website or viewing something on a
website you don't even know if that was
a person looking at it it was more
likely a bot of some sort or a web
crawler or something like that and just
cleaning that data and making sure that
data is actually human beings expressing
real interest in something can be a real
problem
even in the world of purchases you know
there are data quality issues to be
contended with
a good example is institutional buyers
so
you get these people that are buying
things for their company or for their
institution and they're just buying
things on mass for this like huge
organization of thousands of people and
to your systems this looks like one
person buying like everything on the
planet
and that person ends up carrying an
inordinate amount of weight in your
algorithms as a result and it doesn't
really have any meaning to it because
you're not really getting information
about an individual's interest you're
getting information about this
organization's interests so
yeah it's a very long answer to your
question uh gosh i'm not sure how to
pronounce your handle there but
you know what i mean right
the answer is no that's the short answer
there is no no formula there's no um
there's no set way to figure it out you
just have to experiment quite honestly
um the way that you really approach
developing recommender systems is to uh
just try different things and run a b
tests on it
um yeah let's talk about that so how do
i evaluate a recommender system that's a
huge portion of this course actually
because it's not at all obvious
uh there's a lot of ways to do it so a
lot of people in the research community
want to evaluate the quality of their
recommendations offline right because
they're in research they're not actually
going to be deploying this to a real
world system so they can't test it out
on real people uh so what do you do well
one thing you can do is uh measure the
accuracy of the recommendations and you
can do that by saying okay i predicted
that this person would rate this thing
four stars in reality i know they rated
it three stars you know therefore my
accuracy is you know one out of five off
right
um but that's kind of a sketchy way to
evaluate things because
the purpose of a recommender system is
not to predict what you would have rated
something you already saw you're trying
to get new things in front of people
that they haven't seen before or maybe
they have seen it but they didn't know
they wanted it yet right so
really the purpose of a recommender
system
is to show people things that they
didn't even know they wanted yet you
know to read their minds if you will and
that's why it's such a cool field
and that's a very hard thing to measure
without getting real people in the loop
so
in practice when i'm developing a
recommender system and i want to know if
it's good or not the first thing i'm
going to do and we're going to do this
when i go through the code walkthrough
is try it out on myself you know i i'll
throw my own personal data at it see
what recommendations that gives it back
to me and i'll say well does that make
sense does that actually reflect my
interests or is it a bunch of random
crap that um
is irrelevant to me you know and that's
kind of the first line of defense on
figuring out subjectively if i have a
good algorithm or not or if i have
enough data or the quality of my data is
sufficient right the next step would be
to try out some other people you know
get some friends you know get some of
your office mates to say hey try try
this recommender system see what the
results are like for you do you think
they're good do you think they're bad
just get some qualitative feedback i
mean the quantitative accuracy metrics
are good and all but
they're just a very rough guide you know
you have to get it in front of people to
really evaluate it and the ultimate test
is going to be getting it out there in a
live production setting in a controlled
experiment in some sort of an a b test
right so if you have an existing
recommender algorithm and you want to
try a new one you know you just try the
new one at 10
and you measure its results make sure
that it's not you know doing something
terrible to your revenue and if it looks
positive or at least even ramp up that
percentage over time of how much the new
algorithm is getting exposed and
eventually you'll have enough data
collected to actually know for sure if
your algorithm is better or not yeah
again
great question uh with a really long
answer and not a very satisfying one i'm
afraid um it is a hard problem to know
do i have good enough data do i have
enough data and is my algorithm good
enough this is really the this is really
what makes recommender systems hard and
interesting in my opinion but i do have
some
frequently asked questions here
if i'm if i'm honest the most frequently
asked question i get is can i get your
course for free the answer is no
the other question i get is will you do
my homework for me again the answer is
no so we got those out of the way
um
uh but after that
um
i get good questions on this course by
and large um one of the ones i get is
what are the pre
prerequisites
prerequisites that's a hard thing to say
uh for getting into recommender systems
a lot of people you know they'll stumble
across this course they'll say oh that's
cool i can read people's minds with
computers i want to learn that but you
do need some background before tackling
this stuff recommender systems is really
a specialized subset of machine learning
that deals with sparse data like we were
talking about
and um
as such it helps to have a background in
machine learning first and before you
have a background in machine learning it
helps have a background in python and
linear algebra right so you want to make
sure you're coming into this with at
least some computer science experiment
experience
at least some mathematical experience
like we're talking high school level uh
math here nothing too fancy uh but you
need to know what you know how
trigonometry works at least you know one
of the common metrics that we use for
how similar things are is the cosine
metric so at least know what a cosine is
guys at least know what multiple
dimensions are you know these are
important concepts for recommender
systems
um
so if you have that under your belt
you're in a good good starting point um
if you do have some cs some programming
experience
you can probably take this course
successfully it would be even better
though if you had some of the basics of
machine learning under your belt first
and i do offer a more general machine
learning and data science course also
available on manning live video probably
a good place to start if you haven't uh
dipped your feet into the machine
learning waters quite yet
um and yeah uh python programming
obviously a good thing to have i do
include sort of a um
a primer in python so if you do have a
an existing programming experience and
you think you can pick up python pretty
quickly i'll help you do that in this
course but obviously if you know python
ahead of time that also helps as well
but beyond that
i try to keep my courses as accessible
as possible to people i know they go to
a very wide audience with a very wide
diverse range of experiences so i want
to make sure people feel successful in
them right so i try not to dive in too
deep into
you know hardcore algorithms and fancy
mathematical notation i try to explain
things in in human terms as much as
possible you know if you look at like
you know my courses in their reach
around the world um
i've had over 500 000 people take my
courses around the world and it is
mind-boggling the the impact that that's
having it's uh it's really a humbling
thing if you picture like you know the
biggest football stadium in the world
couldn't handle it could not hold all
those students so
the power of online education is just
really amazing and um you know more and
more people are discovering that now
that we're stuck at home so it's good
that we kind of like know how to do this
now we can actually share knowledge this
way
uh can you rec mr co2k can you recommend
large public data sources that are
available online to play around with or
yeah
the uci data repository if you google
that is a great source for uh free open
source data repositories the really big
ones if you go to aws
i don't have the link offhand but if you
search for it i'm sure you can find it
they have a ton of public data sets
available there that are just hosted on
aws you know within s3
and if you're actually you know doing
your machine learning on an aws fleet of
servers on ec2 or sagemaker or what have
you
it's very easy to access and pull in
those large data sets that are hosted on
aws so if you just search for aws data
sets um that will bring you to it as
well
um
what i use in the course is the movie
lens data set let's talk about that
let's go there this is a good segue to
that so if we go to uh
grouplens.org this is kind of my
favorite data set and they have a wide
range of sizes for you to play with so a
good technique when you're developing
machine learning algorithms or
recommender systems is to start with a
small data set and work your way up to
larger data sets that way you can
experiment on your own local pc or a
single host in the cloud and you know
don't start to invest in like you know
more and more of a larger cluster until
you're confident that you're ready to do
so so if you go to data sets here
this takes you to the group lens data
set these are this is called the movie
lens data set and what it is is a
repository of movie ratings that people
have made
i can show you what that looks like if
you go to uh movielens.org it's kind of
like netflix you know they show you a
bunch of movies and ask you to rate them
or at least how netflix used to work
they don't actually do ratings anymore
netflix do they but back in the day this
is how netflix worked so they show you
people a bunch of movies and they ask
them to rate them between one to five
stars and they've done this to actually
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people over the years and they have
actual real data on movie ratings that
you can play with so
one of my favorite one of my favorite
data sets just because it's fun and
because i like movies i worked at imdb
what can i say
uh but it's also easy to understand the
results intuitively right so if you like
put in your own set of data of what
movies you've rated and what movies
you've enjoyed getting back predictions
of what movies that things you might
like that you haven't seen yet
it makes it real you know it's very easy
to understand that and
interpret those results but anyway you
can see they have a large set of data
sets here to choose from they have a 25
million row data set here for when you
want to scale things up
and if you want to start small this is
what we do in the course to get started
there's a small 100 000 rating data set
obviously you're not going to get as
good recommendations from a small data
set as a big one necessarily and also um
these are a little bit out of date these
older data sets this one was last
updated in 2018 so if you want data
about the latest hollywood blockbusters
you're not going to find it reflected in
this data but it's recent enough that
you'll still recognize the movies that
are in it so um a lot of fun uh working
with that data set
and we're gonna do that
shortly uh let me go back to the the
twitch stream here and see what other
questions we might have oh gosh you guys
are asking all sorts of stuff this is
great
uh oh
abner bolsi you went there how can you
start applying for jobs to recommender
systems what is the number of projects
needed before applying yeah this is
actually my next frequently asked
question you read my mind and you just
added one to that frequency of that
question so yeah getting a job getting a
career that's what we're all here for
right
so um
when i was at amazon i was what they
called a bar raiser and a big part of my
job was hiring people and interviewing
people
i actually had the role of having veto
authority for new hires all across the
entire company not just in my own team
so um i was sort of like this uber
hiring manager if you will i literally
interviewed thousands of people while i
was at amazon and hired hundreds of them
so i know a thing or two about getting a
job in this field
so first of all let me uh make it clear
taking an online course is the beginning
of your journey you are not going to get
a job just because you took an online
course you're not going to get a job
because you got a certification at least
not in the united states
by and large you need to show that you
can apply what you've learned and
actually built something with it
so your question is actually very well
thought out you're asking how many
projects do i need um and yeah you're
you're you're head's in the right place
you know so
if i think about the recruiters and the
hiring managers at companies like amazon
and mind you different companies
different countries are going to have
different cultures and different
standards but i'm just talking from my
own experience here
they're gonna be looking for either
someone who you know just graduated from
a college that they know and trust you
know if you graduate from stanford
you're gonna get job offers it's uh
that's just how it works
um
or if you're from a you know
not so well-known university they want
to see that you've applied what you've
learned at least so one thing they'll
actually do is uh go out to like github
and like look at
places like kaggle for people who are
winning coding challenges
and if they find someone who's like you
know new to the field but is really
showing a lot of promise and what
they're accomplishing
online you know they might get a call
and that's another tip too by the way um
these companies don't call them they
call you you know if you apply to these
companies they get so many applications
they don't even look at them
we literally did not look at them they
you want them to find you and to make
yourself discoverable you have to be out
there online you need to be contributing
to open source projects you need to be
you know doing stuff like kaggle
challenges you need to be contributing
to um
whatever you can uh publishing your work
you know just make sure that the work
you're doing
is you know a interesting and be
discoverable brag about it on your
linkedin profile make sure they can find
you on linkedin
whatever it takes just make sure you
have an online presence that makes it
really easy for someone to find you if
they're looking for someone who is
dabbling in recommender systems because
that's the beauty about this field it is
like the most important field of ai and
machine learning out there and people
don't even realize it i mean this is i
can't tell you how much of amazon's
money comes from recommender systems but
it's a lot and the same is true of
places like youtube and netflix right um
google right these these are the biggest
employers and the biggest drivers of the
global economy and recommender systems
are central to what they do and most
people don't even know what recommended
systems are which is my next frequently
asked question what the heck is a
recommender system we'll go there too so
yeah you know just having some
set of a body of work that you can put
out there on the internet related to
recommender systems is going to be
important
for example when i was developing this
course i needed to find a framework to
work within for the course and i came
across this thing called an open source
project called surprise lib
developed by a guy named nicholas hugg i
think it is and if i was a hiring
manager i would give this guy a call i'm
like hey you've demonstrated that you
understand how recommended systems work
you've demonstrated that you can write
good code that is actually functional
it's well structured um you know i want
you on my team right so
it doesn't have to be a lot of projects
it just has to be the right project you
know one that really demonstrates
proficiency
you